it's what we thought
but I can now confirm that the original
creators of the expanse are working with
AMC and they're not working towards
season seven
but something completely different
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV
movie channel
on a hike
[Music]
thank you
so for a while now we've been talking
about how amkron is waiting for its deal
with Amazon to end so it can actually
start producing something in the
universe of the expanse once again and
I'm hearing that those plans are now
taking shape and going a little bit more
formal
since basically season six ended they
have been talking to companies about
maybe producing something but that's
been very informal because at the end of
the day until that you two-year deal
with Amazon ends and they actually have
the right to produce and distribute
something with a new provider they can't
actually do anything so they have been
talking to Apple as I've discussed and
they have been talking to Warner
Brothers
it does seem at the moment that Apple oh
Victory is the most interested but again
if you're a regular side tracker and you
listen to a few of my videos you'll know
that it seems that um Apple say they're
interested in lots of things every rumor
I hear seems to be apple images
they are cash Rich they've got the money
to actually do it so in this case it
does seem that they're the most
interested but what is the rumor and
what is the conversation that's
currently happening well Thai Frank and
Aaron Shankar now Shankar was the um
showrun of the experience and Ty Frank
is one of the co-authors and he was the
sort of lead producer on the TV show as
well in talks apparently to start their
own production company that production
company will then produce
expanse related material for Apple via
am crying
now
I am hearing though that Apple are very
keen to do this but they don't actually
want to make season seven
so before I tell you about that plan I'm
going to tell you a little bit more
about our walk
walking with my mate John Boy here and
we're in the Shropshire Hills so where
are we going what we doing John Boy
we're like you said we're in the
Shropshire Hills uh we're doing a little
walk today from Plum over to Bishop's
Castle it's uh almost 11 miles 2 000
feet of the elevation game
um probably take us was the best part of
the afternoon
hopefully there's a pub and beer in our
future yeah there better be but yeah
I'm just looking I can't see where
there's going to be a pub
but that better be some point I'm
looking to expect to go over one of
these little Hills and there'll be a
golden Oasis
but anyway that's what we're doing today
let's get back to actually while you're
here and tell you a bit more about this
plan for the expanse
just about halfway naked but let's get
to the point of the video
so Aaron Shanker and Ty Franca creating
this production company they plan to do
something with ant cry around the
expanse but Apple don't want them to
necessarily do season seven now we've
talked about this before that they might
actually do sort of some sort of
spin-off now I can confirm that is the
conversation that's happening they will
do some sort of spin-off series
um it may be even a couple of straight
to Apple movies the idea being that
Apple really wants something that is
different and separate to what Amazon
have done and Sci-fi channel did Etc in
the past they want something that's
completely
um apples alone now obviously Thai Frank
is actually one of the original authors
one of the essay Cory and it looks like
the idea basically is to create some
novels that are based in around the
expanse universe that are set within
that 30-year time period now I'm also
told that whatever those storylines will
be will be related to the game in some
way which is in interesting because it
means we might actually see some of the
original characters with her but also
really related to stuff that was
discussed and teased in the sixth season
so my thinking is I'm going to watch the
sixth season again I'm gonna actually
have a bit of a closer look at the game
as well and see over the next few months
if we can figure out what some of those
storylines that they're talking about
might be unfortunately my source is more
on the business end of things
they know about the conversations they
know about contract negotiations and
things like that but they don't
necessarily know much about the creative
conversations that are going on
so
let's put our heads together guys let's
get into the comments now and actually
see what are those some of those
storylines that we think they might be
able to explore in a spin-off series of
the expanse it's really hot
so it really does look like the Aaron
Shankar and Ty Frank are going to be
taking on the role of penguin in a
Parker of what Mark Fergus and Hawk Osby
did for the original Sci-Fi series of
the expanse they're going to be doing
the development work much of the writing
etc etc a lot of the work really they
did before for the expanse but really
taking control of a lot of it themselves
so guys get into the comments to tell me
what you think
is Apple really a bit of a nightmare
scenario or is it to think what I think
Apple do really great sci-fi and they
tend to spend money pretty wisely a
decent budget and they could do
something really interesting or is Apple
the worst and really the biggest problem
for the expanse future
I think
if they're gonna do it's better than
nothing
but most importantly tell me what you
think is it really going to be coming
back are we going to be getting more
expanse or are we just going to be
playing more of a waiting game
I'd love to know what you think please
get into the comments
pill
[Music]
it's really hard
so about a month ago
umkron did actually arrange for all of
the props and sets and a few other
things to be auctioned off so all of the
props from the expanse are gone now this
I'm told was agreed about 12 months ago
when they basically realized Amazon
would not be taking up the option but it
is amkron that actually own all of those
sets and props and things so they could
have kept it forever new project they
were planning with apple the Warner
Brothers or whoever but it seems that
this decision that whatever new project
they do will not be related directly to
Amazon is part of the reason why they've
decided to sell off those props they
actually want the new show to look new
it needs to look different from what
became before so that is the main reason
why they decided to sell them all off
and auction them
there's also the issue though that
amkron need the money they haven't got
many projects on the go at the moment
and the expanse was to be honest their
most major deal so the whole basically
covered thing has not helped them but
also it's been a bit of a lean a few
months for them
so it just adds more weight to the idea
that we're going to actually be getting
a new sort of project something that
looks very different to what we've seen
before right that's it no more talking
we've got five miles to go I'm gonna
knuckle down now and get it done damn it
so if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out you
never miss any of our new videos also
you can go to patreon.com forward slash
Sidetrack where most of our new videos
appear first and you get to see them
without the adverts for a small
contribution each month that really
supports the channel also you can go to
our dedicated website
sidetrack.co.uk where we do stories with
a little bit more meat on the bones of
all the things that we talk about on the
videos so please go check it out stay
safe
get out into the countryside it's
amazing
and I'm so sorry I've breathed very
heavily throughout this video
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]